good morning
or good afternoon if you're in the East
and
um welcome
I'm going to be talking to you today
about
um a subject that's very close to my
heart and I hope it's close to yours and
the title of the presentation I think
says it all
um what will it take to overcome the
Dismal success rate of cancer biomarkers
and molecular Diagnostics and those two
are obviously very closely related I
want to remind you that this
presentation is CME eligible so if you
want to if you want to click that for
your CME credit you can do that now
the um
the story is a really interesting one of
biomarkers and I'm going to take you
through that story
um a little bit about myself first on
the co-director here of complex adaptive
systems and I'm the director of
something called the national biomarker
development Alliance that was developed
over the last two to three years I'm
also a professor of the School of Life
Sciences at Arizona State University and
formerly the deputy director of the
National Cancer Institute before I came
to Arizona State University
um so if we uh if we start now to talk
about the issues today
I'm going to actually talk to you a
little bit about biomarkers and why
biomarkers are the foundation for
personalized medicine and often called
Precision medicine and a little bit on
on what they are and the state of the
field and then we're going to talk about
some of the problems in the field and um
the reproducibility of biomarker
discoveries is a major problem
however I'm going to talk to you a great
deal today about the identification of
the problems in the field and some of
the solutions that we have come to and
I'm hoping that I can convince you today
that although we have real problems
um I think we have the greatest
opportunity that I've seen in the
history of medicine to actually change
what's going on in this field and change
the direction of medicine for patients
and that's going to be a great a great
part of our discussion today so
um let's get right into it
um so biomarkers are a rational
foundation for personalized medicine and
and why is that
um
here's the reality of cancer and we
think about these statistics a lot and
we talk about them a lot but
they're so mind-numbing sometimes that
we kind of forget that they it's
something that is actually ever
increasing and increasingly on economic
disaster in terms of health care so if
you look at these numbers year over year
the number of new cases in the U.S in
2013 was 1.6 million I used to talk
about that number being 1.4 million in
the future we're going to look at
increases uh of up to upwards to 40
percent in terms of cancer especially
obviously in people over the age of 55.
as 77 percent of cancer is diagnosed in
individuals over the age of 55. the good
news is we have a lot of survivors today
and that population is going to also
continue to increase and some of the
morbidities in those patients will
become bigger problems as we as we go
through the next few decades
um the problem with cancer essentially
is that we really haven't done much
about the mortality rate over the last
40 years it's incrementally a little
better but we have a long way to go
um
if you think about The Economic
Consequences of cancer they're they're
really daunting because if you look at a
30 to 40 percent increase and all the
cost of cancer is variously reported uh
it's certainly over 200 billion a year
and uh is moving upwards to probably
Approach at some level at some State uh
the trillion dollar level so uh if you
if you look at that in the context of
molecular Sciences going back uh several
years uh almost 50 years to the
discovery of the Philadelphia chromosome
there is a story that actually has
driven this ideal of personalized
medicine and it's it's actually founded
or it started all those years ago with
the discovery of the Philadelphia
chromosome and this is a chromosome that
has a translocation in the BCR Gene and
the able Gene and that actually that
Fusion Jane
turns out to be the cause certainly the
major factor in the causative pathway
for chronic myelogenous leukemia and so
in 2002 we approved a drug called levac
for this particular disease and at that
stage in 2002 this this particular drug
was Curative for most of the patients
that actually received it and that's
true to this day we learned a lot since
then about how the how this particular
Gene can continue to mutate and change
so resistance develops in these patients
but this story actually started us on a
road to
personalized medicine and there have
been many stories since not enough but a
few we had a recent story for example
example with malignant melanoma where
you know we're seeing B rap that
particular Gene be very very diagnostic
and the causal pathway potentially for
some of the melanoma that we see so this
was not a bad basis to start thinking
about Precision medicine and um if you
um if you then think about a little
further about health care the reality is
going back to the cancer
burden that we are anticipating in the
next 15 to 20 years by the way this
isn't just true for the U.S this is a
global issue and globally it's quite
profound in terms of the numbers of
cancer patients but if you look at
Health Care spending going back to that
number of cancer patients that we
anticipate in 2013 it was about
somewhere around 13 around three
trillion dollars sorry and we expect
that to increase by four percent or more
per year for the foreseeable future so
it looks as though this particular
idea of Health Care spending increasing
is going to continue to be a fact of
life and I was on a panel the other day
in Washington where a very prominent
payer was able to predict and and in a
very scary fashion I might add that
currently many cancer patients are
spending will have to spend half their
income on treating their disease and in
the future it could be a hundred percent
of their income so uh this is uh this is
these are very frightening statistics
and so 21st century medicine early
detection disease prevention targeted
Diagnostics targeted Therapeutics is the
way that we see the future and if you
you know if you believe that which I
hope you do then
biomarkers those molecular changes that
actually are are diagnostic of the
disease often uh are going to be the are
going to be the key to the future of
personalized medicine so it's all about
biomarkers and you can see uh that in
the numbers of meetings we hold the
numbers of conferences that are held the
number of Publications biomarkers are a
very big deal
so their potential can almost
not be estimated at this point it's
probably the highest value proposition
in personalized medicine today and uh to
realize this value
um
they're going to have to be developed
for therapy development for example
markers of efficacy already in use in
terms of companion Diagnostics early
detection this is a very important area
that isn't going all that well for
cancer yet because the molecular
Diagnostics industry doesn't have a
great business model at this point
um
choosing treatments or stratifying
patients is already well underway and we
we have enabled some of that through
whole genome sequencing
projects like the cancer genome Atlas
which Francis Collins and I started when
I was at NCI has paid off in many ways
to begin to stratify these patients
based on their molecular profiles
assessment of treatment prognosis are
essentially determining what the
clinical outcome is going to be by using
biomarkers or predicting response to
therapy those are not the same thing
um prediction in terms of surveillance
uh in in terms of the whole of
population surveillance is very very
promising
um and the whole issue of uh surrogate
endpoints for clinical testing surrogate
endpoints we're going to talk a little
bit about in a minute but this is a very
important concept and one that needs a
lot of attention from our communities so
the value proposition of biomarkers and
their relationship to the achievement of
personalized medicine is an absolute
so a few definitions and and then we're
going to talk a little bit about the
state of the field but this is a
confusing field in a lot of ways I know
the meeting here about 18 months ago was
some of the smartest biomarker people I
know and it took us the whole morning to
come to an agreement on a definition for
a biomarker however
um as in all things there is uh there is
an official definition for a biomarker
but there's a lot of confusion around
this definition a characteristic
biological or physical and it can be an
image blood pressure is a biomarker so
it's not just about molecular changes
that is objectively measured and
evaluated usually a change as an
indication of normal biological
processes pathogenic processes or
pharmac or pharmacologic responses uh
into a therapeutic intervention in other
words you can measure use a biomarker to
measure a change once you give someone a
drug ideally this is very important it
should be clinically relevant fit for
purpose that's an FDA term that says you
have to know the context of use for your
biomarker if you're going to submit it
for regular jewelry review it has to be
measurable reproducible quantifiable and
directly reflect the current state
whether it's normal or altered that's
all those are a lot of parameters and
they're all very important a surrogate
endpoint and sometimes this is called a
surrogate biomarker is a laboratory
measurement or physical sign that is
used in therapeutic trials as a
substitute for a clinically meaningful
endpoint that is a direct measure of how
a patient feels functions or survives
and that is expected to predict the
effect of the therapy Bob Temple said
that in 1995 from FDA and that's still
in effect so a biomarker that
substitutes for a clinical endpoint
is a surrogate endpoint and you have to
remember that just measuring a molecular
parameter does may not tell you how a
patient will feel function or survive so
as a consequence of that we do not have
many surrogate endpoints in in the
cancer field
cardiovascular disease has quite a few
of those
there aren't many there are not many
surrogate endpoints period because it's
extraordinarily difficult to find
biological molecular changes that are in
the causal pathway of the disease and
it's also very very difficult to do the
trials to relate it back to how a
patient feels functions or survives a
lot of biomarkers fail because of that
problem
so um
a couple of other terms that you need to
know obviously to measure a biomarker
you have to be extraordinarily careful
in building an assay that is sensitive
and has specificity so the extent to
which an assay correctionally correctly
identifies the disease when the disease
is really there is a true positive
specificity is the extent to which an
assay identifies true negatives when the
disease is truly absent and that's in
the presence of all compounding factors
Precision is the closest of agreement
between independent test results once
you obtain your assay under defined
conditions fit for purpose is an FDA
term that's used in their biomarker
qualification program which defines the
context of use assay development
specific for stage of the drug
development considers the intended
clinical use and defines the regulatory
requirements so this is a very very
defined pathway now and then just uh
those of you that aren't in the essay a
development business you have to know
how your how your essay is performing
normal populations are generally never
totally normal and disease populations
are never exactly homogeneous and so you
have to perform a lot of operations and
a lot of tests to determine what the
overlap is between those populations and
that's called the receiver operating
curve it's been around for decades but
essays don't generally specifically
distinguish disease from normal with 100
accuracy so this is the way you actually
come to analytical validation analytical
validation is what defines a molecular
Diagnostics diagnostic versus a
biomarker so a lot of terms and there's
a lot of confusion in the field about
these terms and not easily not easily
understood so as a consequence it's
produced a lot of problems for us in the
field so just so we're on the same page
biomarkers essentially that we're
talking out today we're talking about
molecular biomarkers today we're not
talking about Imaging or some of the
other things that we could be talking
about but we're talking about changes in
the genome and or the or the
transcriptome or the proteome micro rnas
it's this whole range of molecular
changes that can occur so proteomic
information genomic information to help
a physician make a clinical decision
about a patient care that's increasing
uh they exist generally in the
literature and clinical trials at
various stages of validation and you can
read about a biomarker in the literature
and not really understand uh the extent
to which has been either analytically
validated or clinically validated
um and you can now qualify these kinds
of things these biomarkers uh with the
FDA for a specific context of use and
that you can go online to FDA site and
see what the qualification programs look
like molecular Diagnostics use this
information to distinguish between
normal and diseased tissues and to help
a clinician make a decision
these molecular Diagnostics are
analytically validated and clinically
validated and they receive approval from
FDA on a couple of pathways through a
PMA or a 510k and I'll come back to that
in just a second and these agents when
they become molecular Diagnostics they
may be used as Diagnostics and or
companion diagnostics for drugs
so just so we're all on the same page in
terms of FDA here
um so if you have a biomarker that you
believe is is on on the road to becoming
molecular diagnostic then there are
there's a lot of there's a lot of work
that you have to do so pnas are
pre-market applications and they
actually uh involve a lot of data and a
lot of steps and a lot of money so
molecular biomarkers to be used as
companion Diagnostics or molecular
Diagnostics are categorized as class
three high-risk devices and so you need
the support of data through an IDE
essentially an investigation device
exemption trial to show that your
biomarker is going to do a what you say
is going to do it's analytically
validated and it's clinically validated
a 510k is an easier route through the
FDA because there's an approved device
or a predicate device and you still have
to collect the data through an IDE
uh trial so these are you know these are
very very similar Pathways the PMA
application is the entry pathway uh for
a device for example now for a molecular
diagnostic that's going to be used in
the clinic quite broadly consider a
high-risk device and then in July of
this year FDA has indicated that it's
going to regulate laboratory developed
tests historically it's not regulated
these tests it's going to start its
regulation on a risk basis essentially
with those tests that are already in the
marketplace that are done under in under
the clear regulations essentially which
have nothing to do with the FDA by the
way so they're going to start with those
tests that are considered high risk and
over the next nearly a decade they're
going to phase in other laboratory
developed tests and you can read those
you can read those new regulations in
the Federal Register and the draft
guidance is out which means you can
comment on this and there is everybody
is in your reform agreement about this
and you have a chance to comment on it
so
um so to take you a little bit through
the state of the biomarker science or
the biomarker field
um I want you know I want to just do a
little summary for you so you know where
we are so do we have a lot of biomarkers
yes we have a lot of biomarkers they're
we're washing biomarkers my colleague
here
um George post
um who is the co-director of conflict
adaptive systems with me here at ASU
publish a paper in nature all the way
back in 2011. this has gotten bigger
that balloon has gotten bigger actually
but he estimated just the number of
papers documenting thousands of
biomarkers was over 150 000. we normally
use less than 100 biomarkers in the
clinics that will give you some idea of
the state of the science in terms of
what gets approved one of the areas
obviously that we have bet very heavily
on in the molecular Sciences is protein
so those are the molecules that do the
work of the cell
lots of these have been submitted in one
guys or another to the FDA but there's
been less than one approved per year
since the early 1990s so there are lots
of there are lots of bias in these
studies there are no standards that are
being adhered to on a national basis
reproducibility across the labs is a
problem etc etc so as a consequence this
says hit the molecular Diagnostics
industry pretty hard in terms of uh
getting technologies that are
reproducible robust and can withstand
the scrutiny of regulatory review
so um
as a consequence of this I mean proteins
are not being approved
um
we don't have that in any uh Diagnostics
approved at all yet in in terms of
cancer but one thing we are seeing and
have been seeing for decades is in
cancer especially where many many too
many of our clinical trials are failing
um and that has to do in many ways with
the biomarker space and biomarkers not
being appropriately either qualified or
analytically validated and when you get
into late phase clinical trials we're
having a lot of attrition long duration
trials and very high costs and and if
you look forward in this uh in this
space in terms of pharmaceutical
development it it's going to get worse
not better as we bifurcate these
diseases into more and more subtypes
this is going to be a really interesting
problem that the pharmaceutical industry
is facing
the cost of a PMA in case you want you
want to get in the Diagnostics business
it's pretty expensive and it involves
several areas
um you have to know first of all you
have to discover the biomarker then you
have to essentially do some early
development on it and
um then there is the process of getting
an IDE essentially getting a device
trial set up and you have to do clinical
safety testing then you have to do a
pivotal clinical study and then you have
to apply for your PMA all of that costs
money and it's somewhere between 94 and
100 million dollars which essentially is
this is pretty equivalent to what we see
with filing an IND for a drug and
obviously this makes it very difficult
to get into this field especially if if
you don't have a pretty good idea that
your biomarker is going to succeed as a
molecular diagnostic
so recently we've seen a lot of this
kind of data and this kind of these
kinds of questions
on the cover of all kinds of uh journals
and magazines now I should tell you this
issue has been on the cover of science
it's been on the cover of nature
um however scientifically we know we've
got a problem when it's on the cover of
The Economist or it's on the cover of
the New Yorker so uh this is this issue
of reproducibility in research has
become a national conversation and a lot
of the reproducibility issues are in the
biomarker space and I'll come back to
that
um
this is just on the science nature and
and plos covers on this kind of thing so
you know we do have a problem uh we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that and what it means so how widespread
is the problem I just picked off a few
of these but you can go look in the
literature and you can go look at papers
retract it Etc but
um so this is just a few of these
um I just looked at some of the
molecular therapy studies for example
five of the seven larger studies didn't
classify patients better than chance and
Library signatures we I know about this
study essentially to predict patient
response was named one of the
breakthroughs actually in 2006 and uh in
2009 it was shown uh to be wrong in
terms of labeling and uh due to labeling
and indexing errors in the Laboratories
um but these are the two studies that
have gotten the most attention and
published on uh essentially is the Amgen
study where Amgen scientist attempted to
reproduce 53 of the seminal Publications
in the field that they were interested
in which is drug development and these
were discoveries that were purported to
be great targets essentially they could
produce reproduce only 11 percent of
those and Bayer had a similar experience
with a rate of 25 so this is uh this
reflects I mean this is diagnostic uh no
pun intended of the of the field and
um I would like to challenge you to
believe that it's also one of the
biggest opportunities we have and I'll
tell you why
um so this is impacting our ability to
deliver the discoveries that are so
important to patients to patients and so
I think these are all fixable problems
and so what I came to ASU uh a little
coming up on two years ago or so
um I decided when I was at NCI we worked
closely with FDA to see if we could
develop you know what is the trajectory
for a biomarker what do you need to do
to get it from a discovery all the way
into patients we didn't get very far
with that problem we worked on other
problems but we this is a very sticky
one so when I came to ask you I decided
that we would tackle this problem uh
because this is not a problem
for the government for the industry for
advocacy groups for universities it's a
problem for all of us and so what we
decided to do is see if we could bring
these sectors together to begin to
discuss the problem identify the problem
and figure out what the solutions might
be so that's the story that I want to
tell you
um
so we set up something called the
national biomarker development Alliance
and um essentially it's a it's a
transector Alliance that's assembling
people who want to change this really
want to change this uh organizations and
stakeholders to develop a deep
understanding of what the problems are
and I would argue that most of us didn't
know what they were when we started and
also to create some solutions that are
implementable and will actually change
this and bring these bring these
biomarkers through to success and also
really change the lives of patients
so we started um
gosh it's about 18 months ago or so a
little more than that holding workshops
around just starting to ask ourselves
questions about how do we discover
biomarkers and then how do we actually
develop them do we have a system to
develop them and ending in the last we
had a last one in July talking about you
know what are the clinical trials and
what are the real challenges in clinical
trials for biomarkers and we worked our
way through a whole range of problems
and issues that I'll tell you a little
bit about
so this is what we've learned and so I
know very few slides I'm going to tell
you so almost two years of work of due
diligence on understanding what the
problems really are
so I can I can show you here what the
problems really are in this graphic
because this is the graphic that we've
come to one this is an end-to-end
process developing a biomarker is an
end-to-end process you start with
Discovery and you end with biomarker
validation and a clinical trial be it
for as a companion diagnostic or as a
diagnostic per se
each of these areas up here essentially
are these represent real decision points
in here
where you have to make a decision to
move a biomarker not unlike a drug from
one of these areas to another and we
distinguish early Discovery from
translatable or later Discovery from
assay development although these clearly
overlap and this overlaps but they are
quite distinguished distinguishable
sorts of modules in this whole process
the qualification process and then the
validation process
we are really concerned over here
because so many things are are leaving
early discovery that should not leave
early Discovery just as we need to kill
drugs more quickly we need to kill
biomarkers more quickly so this is a
graphic representation of what I believe
an end-to-end process should look like
and if you look at this we need
standards at every one of these decision
points we need standards even starting
over here now I should tell you that
what I'm about to tell you
is I think the opportunity
of a lifetime in terms of cancer
research I think that we have over
decades been making fabulous discoveries
we now have the opportunity to take some
of those discoveries not all but some
and in the future maybe more uh through
processes that will more quickly get
these discoveries to patients and I
think that's the opportunity that will
actually totally erase any issues of
reproducibility and concerns for
reproducibility because we all know as
scientists that in early Discovery there
are discoveries that will be very
difficult if not impossible to reproduce
and and that's okay because Discovery is
Discovery in many cases but if you if
you want your Discovery to end up in a
patient there are things that you have
to do here to get to here and one of
those things we have discovered is
standards and we are not good in our
communities at standards but we're going
to have to become very good at standard
words so to go from here to here this is
well this is one of the things that we
discovered absolutely we're going to
need standards so um
we pursued each of these modules and try
to determine what it was in each of
those modules that made biomarkers fail
and what we came to is the two big
culprits here are in that Discovery and
translatable Discovery Realm
and
about
this is this is to talk to talk to a lot
of scientists and every scientist will
tell you almost to a scientist that the
biggest barrier that we have in
biomarkers is the complexity of the
science
and everyone agrees on that the
complexity of the science is what it is
and we're going to have to understand
that as we deconvolute the complexity
we're going to have to bring rigor
Beyond understanding uh whatever we can
deconvoluted in terms of complexity we
have to take that piece of information
and turn it into knowledge but this is
the most cited barrier by the scientists
in the field actually
um
after we got by after and if you look at
why that's true
um and those of you that work in the
genomics field notice we learned this in
the Canter genome Atlas absolutely is
that the landscape of genomic
alterations in cancer is overwhelming
and if you look at this slide you'll see
that these are mutations in individual
non-small cell lung cancer and these are
the drug targets and I can tell you from
doing 500 samples in every tcga tumor
every individual has some slight
variations you can group these into
subtypes based on their molecular
variations but in fact these this is
very concerning in terms of the
development of new drugs but this is
this reflects the complexity of the
disease that we're talking about and
then if you go to the protein level
again supporting my colleagues on the
complexity question
um this is uh this is fine 500
biomarkers and this is the connections
essentially conditionally dependent
Connections in glioblastoma and this is
a tumor that we do very little about in
terms of therapy as you know but the
complexity is reflecting the networks
that actually are communicating with
each other at the protein level which is
extraordinarily complex and then if you
take this to the more popular level that
we're dealing with today which is
Pathways and we we have discerned a
select number of Pathways and we like
those Pathways
um it's it's very very convenient to
think about Pathways the pathways are
convenient models they are no more than
that and it's not that simple as all
these pathways are interacting in real
time so just supporting our colleagues
the biology is extraordinarily complex
but let's look beyond the biology and
say that we have those hundreds of
thousands of biomarkers every single
year
is it a solvable problem and I would
argue that absolutely is we made a
really important discovery that I think
could change the field and I hope uh
it's it when I say it's a surprising
discovery it shouldn't be surprising to
any of us but what we found is the
following the problems in biomarker
Discovery
usually begin in early Discovery so
essentially
it makes them impossible to reproduce
often and the big killer here is
starting with an irrelevant
clinical question in other words a lot
of our biomarker Discovery doesn't start
with a relevant clinical question and we
back into a question you know we
discover something and then we go
looking for a rationale that's not the
way to to do something you want to put
into patients so um
so biomarkers are generally based on
convenience samples unfortunate but true
they have a lot of people who discover
biomarkers don't know much about
statistical design
we don't have technology standards
generally that are applied universally
we know little sometimes about the
provenance of our data and the data
management aspects of this are critical
and the uh the analysis and the
analytics are often inappropriate or
inadequate
so all that adds up to this
these are the key barriers
in these six
I I want to call these strategic
elements of biomarker Discovery also
lies the solution
so
the number one I think most important
aspect of this is probably the lack of a
relevant biomarker appropriate clinical
question and that means we have to very
carefully assess fireworkers relative to
what they're going to be used for by a
clinician for making making a decision
about a patient
inadequate experimental design either in
terms of the statistical design whether
that's actually going to address the
clinical question poor quality
biospecimens this is the bane of at
least my intestines and I hope it will
become yours because we know how to
solve this problem but many of our
samples are inadequate sometimes they're
you know are our experimental designs
are sampling you know from the wrong
populations Etc
lack of or disregard protects standards
and poor quality data and inadequate
analytics and Analysis and these we call
kind of the big six
if you go into literature and you read a
paper on biomarkers and you can't put a
check mark by each of these and you
likely do not have a biomarker
so uh
just a couple of words here about this
in terms of looking at a couple of these
so this is essentially uh the her2 test
and if you look at the differences here
in IHC and fish and breast cancer there
is a loss of signal with time to
fixation and there is a gain of signal
on the right hand side essentially in
colon cancer that's a big deal and if
you look at the statement from in
viviamed without knowledge about tissue
processing methods and Assurance of
Rapid tissue fixation protein expression
data are unreliable and understanding of
pathway activity is not possible that's
a very damning kind of statement and if
you look at um sorry I'm going to go
back
and now I'm going to go forward
if you look then too at the entire
landscape of devices that's coming along
now every one of them will have
different requirements in terms of those
six parameters that I just mentioned and
so our goal is to raise the bar for body
specimen quality for all of these areas
and um we're doing something about that
bias is a big deal in all of these
studies and experimental design as good
as you think you are specimen collection
is another area where it is is one of
the key areas actually where where bias
really makes a difference and then
there's multiple observations Don Berry
wrote this paper uh in 2012. it's very
relevant in the sense that when you're
when you're making recordings of
observations over time in in
multiplicities are you know our rampant
in the work that we do the chances of
false positives become very high
so all this leads me to
um a conversation that we had with FDA
and they've been very very happy in
terms of working with us on the national
biomarker development Alliance so Janet
Woodcock who is um the deputy director
there for uh for drugs and and
probably one of the most Innovative
Regulators on the planet if not the most
she made a statement at our first
meeting of the nvda where she said it is
not fda's job to develop the standards
for biomarker development it's the job
of the affected communities and that's
true
so
um what we have done is to pick up on
what she said all the way back in 2000
and I think 2002 or three in something
called the critical path initiative
which you can find on fda's website is
that
FDA realizes that essentially biomarker
development and streamlining clinical
trials are the two most aspects of
really improving medical product
development in this Century so FDA
agrees with us and they have told us
that they are not going to develop these
standards and they're not going to
develop these processes it's our job
so the nvda mission is to
collaboratively create standards meaning
best practices guidelines standard
operating procedures and we're not going
to reinvent Wheels if there are good
guidelines out there then we're going to
use them
for a systems-based end-to-end biomarker
development process or processes and in
doing so Advanced Precision medicine
that statement means a lot and it says a
lot uh and I believe it can be done and
I believe having a system that is end to
end so that an investigator has some
Direction when you start to develop a
biomarker will be invaluable
so coming back to this
um we have I think we have I've told you
enough about this essentially that you
understand it's an end-to-end process
these are all decision points this is
critical once you move into this phase
uh all kinds of things start to happen
in terms of the big six that we talk
about if the big six weren't considered
over here the chances of failure over
here become monumental
so um I repeat you know write clinical
question
um write experimental design
great samples technology standards
um
great data and great analytics will take
you to the finish line so these problems
are all solvable
other fields that face problems like
this successfully and I think we can as
well and I think we will and changing
the whole field of cancer research uh
without a compromising Innovation and
Discovery or early Discovery is going to
be critical to actually achieving
precision and personalized medicine for
patients and I think we have to deliver
on this promise we have to
not because we're all dependent on you
know
the government for Grants or our
institutions for salary increases
because we publish a lot
it's because we can actually save the
lives of patients and we can prevent
this disease we can detect it early if
we solve these problems and that will
change that won't just change cancer
that will change every other chronic
disease actually every other disease I
talk all the time to people in the
psychiatric disease field or in you know
in Alzheimer's Etc they have exactly the
same problems we have so the problems
with biomarkers are pretty rampant so
we're doing some things now to start to
bring solutions to the table
um
we're starting to develop uh this this
uh idea of can we can we actually talk
about surrogate endpoints and begin to
Define it in a new way uh the chances of
actually us being able to come up with
single changes that are going to be
absolutely aligned with the uh the
clinical endpoints that FDA recognizes
are increasingly unlikely maybe out
there there's going to be a way to look
at the natural history of the disease
and and redefine uh surrogate endpoints
we're holding up we're holding a
workshop on this in December in
Washington
so um the other thing is we're we're
trying to set up a Commons for biomarker
designs and clinical trials protocols so
the best of the best will be available
to everybody and we're holding something
called convergence conferences beginning
this December to talk about what do we
have to do for biospecimen standards to
get reproducibility not just in genomics
and proteomics but in other aspects of
molecular markers as well and we want to
partner with the College of American
pathology to bring this back to
hospitals so that it will impact
patients
um and then
um we'd like you to join us in this we
hope that you will join us um and become
part of the solution and you can go
online and see us at
www.nbda biomarkers.org and you you your
institution is welcome to join us the we
haven't started our membership drive but
it will be starting in about a week and
uh this is uh we're in Scottsdale
Arizona but we are actually virtual we
have um probably about 50 scientists
working with us and a lot more joining
us
um so I want to have time for questions
uh so I'm going to stop there but just
to give you a an idea that we're we're
working things are happening we actually
this is the Press Club in January where
we launch the nvda people like Janet
Woodcock was there and a lot of other
people and these are some pictures of
our workshops when I say workshops
people are really working they don't
come to listen to you know endless
PowerPoint presentations like this one
and and
um and then go home uh or more likely
work on their computer but uh they work
we actually work together to try to come
up with Solutions and to first of all
identify the real problem and come up
with Solutions so
um we are underway we think that um you
know we're we're going to actually bring
some new thinking to the whole biomarker
Space it is the most important
action I think any of us can take in
terms of enabling this whole concept and
it's still a concept in many ways of
precision or personalized medicine but
there's much work to do and uh if you go
online and you look at the nvda website
um you'll see and you'll you'll be able
to access actually many of the reports
that are up there a lot of the things
that I've told you today uh there there
is every opportunity here for us to
reshape this entire field and it is us
it is uh it is the job of the
stakeholders it's our job so I'm going
to stop there and
um happy to talk more about biomarkers
I'm gonna we have some questions and I'm
going to take some
um
we actually have a lot of questions
um so I'm going to
um I'm going to actually
um take them from the top and
um
so some of them are comments but um so
somebody was was very nice and said that
there was an excellent talk thank you
for that the details are very important
to achieving the final goal
um
let me see here we go okay uh how do you
see the tools of the field defining the
level of deep research that appears to
be driven by other factors at this time
with advancements overlooking the finer
details gained by detailed investigation
um
so you're absolutely right and this
question is coming from Deborah at vkt
lab Consulting
um
so
you you've asked the question that
actually I think
is the reason that we find ourselves
where we are and that question
essentially is we um we've not ever
taken the time to figure out what are
those details that will take us to
success we're just in this frenetic
period of doing Discovery and Discovery
and Discovery some of that has to do
with not being able to actually
understand the field in some ways or in
any ways other of the biology certainly
but others some of it has to do with
just our unwillingness to accept the
fact that the details matter and
um your absolutely you're also
absolutely right about the fact that as
we make these advancements you would
Overlook detail at your apparel there's
no doubt about that
so a second question
um
so when I say it's not that simple
um I'm not sure exactly what the
question is here but the questioner is
saying uh and this is Charles is saying
do you mean in relation to complexity of
cancer I don't know when I said that in
the talk but uh none of this is simple
so I could have actually said that about
cancer obviously in terms of its
complexity but I will also say that
solving this problem is not at all
simple I've never said it simple
actually it's as I say if I if I look at
those six parameters they're all quite
complex but pixable so I think though I
think I think it's complex at every
level Charles and that doesn't make it
daunting it just makes it complex and
you know I would my whole admonition on
complexity is Embrace complexity because
if you don't and if you can't then we're
not going to advance from this field and
in this field or a lot of other areas
surrounding cancer
um so um
Mike asks
um for the FDA to expend energy to
provide guidance to the biomarker
development Community work is required a
very very dirty word and concept to all
government employees
well okay Mike
um I was a government employee and
worked very hard and you know there are
lots and lots and lots of hard-working
government employees I don't think
that's going to be the issue and if you
think about
if you think about actually
um
the issues of what it's going to take to
regulate the numbers of biomarkers that
are coming in the number of drugs that
are coming in
especially now that that FDA has
proposed regulating the laboratory
developed tests and let me just spend a
second on that
um
the laboratory developed tests
I have been around for a long time you
know they have all kinds of names and
and they're being used routinely in lots
of ways but understand that this
laboratory develop developed test story
has stymied the development of the
molecular Diagnostics industry you can
go through the presentation and the
submission of a PMA and you can actually
present it to the FDA and you can have
your PMA approved and you may need to
sell your test uh and rightly so for I
don't know say it's a thousand dollars
the next day someone can come out with a
laboratory laboratory develop test and
sell it for whatever they choose maybe
it's ten dollars or twenty dollars or a
hundred dollars so it really undermines
the business model we don't talk about
that in the regulation of uh laboratory
developed tests and maybe we shouldn't
but it's a big deal in terms of this
entire field so
um I think
you're right it's going to take a lot of
work from on the part of the of the FDA
but I think the I think the I think the
FDA is up to it I think they have the
Personnel I think they're ready to do it
and they've given themselves enough time
to do it and I think they'll do it very
very well
um so laboratory developed tests by the
way
um
there is some concern too about
um and so many of our biomarkers are
being used as laboratory developed tests
there's nothing you know particularly
wrong about that if in fact they
followed a big six and they're really
robust and they're measuring what you
think they're measuring so the um the
other issue though is that laboratory
developed tests
obviously obviously if they're if
they're done in one laboratory not
reproduced in another laboratory and not
actually being challenged anywhere they
may or may not be measuring what you
think they're going to measure and so
FDA in its wisdom I think is saying we
need to know the test is reproducible we
need to know that the data are robust
and especially if it's a high-risk
situation so um
so let me uh let me answer the next
question I spent a little time on
laboratory develop tests because this is
a very confusing issue and one that will
be sorted out I believe in uh the next
uh probably the next five to ten years
but as I said when we went through the
sides uh there's only uh there's not a
lot to concern those people who have a
laboratory developed tests because
they're going into a queue and it's
going to take some time for FDA to
actually sort out the risk factors here
but if you have a high-risk test you are
going to have to go through a PMA would
be my guess so
um they have to get ready for that so we
have a we have a question from prakash
um and it says are these standards
proprietary or open and how do we access
standards so it's an interesting
question
um if I look across the modules that I
showed you that the nvda has come up
with and
um maybe I can just go back to that
there I'm sorry if I look at these
modules
there aren't any standards there are no
standards I mean when you're when you're
deciding to go from here to here uh
there are no there are no standards to
tell you that you have essentially
designed for example an experiment
that's going to answer the right going
to answer the clinical question
um and when you get to translatable
Discovery there's very little to tell
you what standards you have to have in
terms of what's he going to take to
scale this up I mean you may have a test
that works great in you know in in five
samples or ten samples but if you want
to scale this up you know is it scalable
you have no way of knowing that unless
you have some way of standardizing what
it's going to take to scale your test up
um you know we have no real standards
for antibodies to speak of so we don't
have very many good antibodies as you
know commercially available antibodies
are often not very good so in answer to
precautious question we have almost no
standards and when you get out here to
qualifying your biomarker standards
start to be important and certainly when
you get into clinical trials there are
lots of Standards but if you don't have
any standards and you get out here and
you have to comply with standards uh you
probably your test is probably not going
to be sufficiently robust to get through
biomarker qualification which is now an
official process with the FDA and you
should go online to fda's website and
look up the qualification process very
interesting very interesting process
it's been a very slow sort it's been a
very slow slow series of developments
but it's actually we are qualifying we
just qual I saw an announcement
yesterday of a biomarker having
qualified through this process mostly
this process skipped and we go right
over here but before I leave this what
we're trying to do at nbda is to get the
communities to come together to create
these standards and then to partner with
places like the College of American
Pathologists and ASCO and aacr and some
of the laboratory especially some of the
laboratory associations that actually
can Implement these at the patient level
so we do lots of things in our
Laboratories that never get translated
to the patients so we want to bring this
to patients in a way that it's going to
be broadly translatable across all the
communities Community Hospitals
especially
that's a great question
um so we have a question from Deborah
and so
it says that we've heard about c-desk
believe me we've heard a lot about C
disk
um so Ken buto who's here with me at ASU
actually helped to at NC when I was at
NCI we helped to get C disk on their way
so it's these are existing standards to
support the acquisition exchange
submission and archive archiving of
clinical research data and there is
enormous Synergy with this and I would
say that c disk in my opinion represents
the future
there is an example of uh groups taking
the lead and these were initially were
government agencies but it's now much
broader and the whole issue of data
which we did not talk much about in this
talk but as you know big data is is one
of the veins of our existence right now
it's a big plus and that we're getting
enormous amounts of molecular data but
it's also a major negative in the sense
that we don't have the analytics and we
don't have the standards for the data
cdisk is one of those I think very very
important right through kind of
community activities where people are
working together very very closely to
make sure that once you get into the
clinic that the data that you're
submitting is of high quality and you do
have data standards and I would argue
that we should have C disk like kinds of
activities all the way along this
pipeline and what drives this green
arrow is data so in early Discovery once
you start collecting data if if that
data is not sufficiently robust that
it's going to take you all the way over
here so when cdos kicks in kicks in for
clinical trials then you've got a
problem and so I you know I really
applaud cdisk for all the work that they
have done and will do and our goal is to
make sure that we have standards that
allow us to go from Discovery to a
translatable discovery or a technology
and move it through essay development
and performance in a way that it
qualifies and can meet C disk
performance measures
so we have a question from Carmen and um
so good question she's asking is there
any relationship with the FDA with the
nvda alliance in the biomarker cluster
Alliance in Europe and are you aware of
the programs on translation into product
under the EU programs and are we indeed
ready for having a product since there
are no other standards
first of all yes we're very aware of the
biomarker cluster Alliance where as I
say we launched the nvda in January so
we're just and we've spent 18 months in
due diligence before we launched in
January so we'd spend a lot of time
understanding the problems we are just
now setting up our relationships and we
hope and we hope that we can partner
with the um with the biomarker cluster
we know of their work and um we're very
very uh supportive of what they're doing
and then um I also were very aware of
what's going on in the EU in terms of
many of the programs many of them are
actually I think quite Innovative and
quite exciting and um
we in many ways are looking to Europe uh
some of our biomarkers or some of the
biomarkal work that's going on in Europe
is along the lines that we have laid out
for nvda and so we're very supportive I
think I think in many ways Europe has
appreciated and understood this uh this
need for standards uh well before
anybody else did
so um I don't think there are any really
clear standards let me give you one
example
um
when I was at the National Cancer
Institute Dr Carolyn Compton who
actually is with me here and is our
chief medical officer now for uh the
national environment for development
Alliance created over about a five-year
period best practices for a buy specimen
collection and those are up on nci's
website
as as a not as a national force or as a
as a community we have never adopted
those standards and my fear is that the
government will actually come in and
Implement those standards and I don't
mean necessarily NIH but this could
become an item for congress in terms of
the whole issue of the Affordable Care
Act trying to get the best care to
patients patient samples are critical
patient samples are the stuff of
personalized medicine so we really need
people to adopt the standards for tissue
collection and stewardship and all the
things that are really really matter
about a patient's sample the worst thing
that can happen is a patient gifts their
sample and they find out the sample is
lost or it's misvantaged and so they
don't get the they don't get the benefit
of actually having given their sample in
the first place
um
so um
I I want to stop and end on time because
I know everybody has uh has uh
incredible schedules
I I want to thank all of you for being
online today I want to encourage you to
embrace this opportunity
if this
fee can take advantage of solving these
very fixable problems then I believe
that cancer research will receive a lot
more positive attention a lot more
funding not just from the government but
from private foundations and others so
that the science will get better and
better and we can deliver all of those
discoveries to patients there is no
reason for us not to do this none and
through the National Environmental
development Alliance I hope we can pull
this off with your help your
organization is free to join us and as I
say if you go online in about a week
you'll see how to join us online so
thank you very much for joining us this
morning and uh go forth and change the
world thank you
thank you